le pays des merveilles il existe
pourtant il a été dans l'imagination de
lewis carroll et il est grave est
aujourd'hui dans l'imaginaire de tim
burton dont le monde cinématographique
on le sait est un doux mélange de fable
de contes et de fantasmes tim burton qui
nous a accordé un long entretien vous
l'entendrez juste après avoir découvert
des images de son dernier film une alice
au pays des merveilles revue mais pas
corrigé nathalie et r elle a toujours sa
robe bleue et ses longs cheveux blonds
mais elle a grandi à l'iss tu sembles
avoir eu un différend avec une créature
dotée de griffes acérées et je continue
de rêver pour le pays des merveilles et
en cauchemar récurrent un cauchemar
qu'elle va soudain revivre à l'âge de 19
ans alice est revenue au pays des
merveilles
plus que tu es parti l'impitoyable reine
rouge a pris le pouvoir
alice est un personnage très célèbre et
très populaire et ce qui m'a vraiment
intéressé c'était de l'interpréter en
tant qu'adolescente parce que ça n'a
jamais été fait avant
comprenez moi cette suite d'alice au
pays des merveilles
écrite par lewis carroll six ans après
le premier opus une histoire tout aussi
loufoque et dont s'est emparé avec
gourmandise tim burton déluge de
couleurs et d'imagination le tout en
trois dimensions sans oublier les
personnages truculents à commencer par
l'horrible reine rouge
jme par l'épousé actrices fétiches du
réalisateur ouais mon petit cochon
j'aime poser mes pieds douloureux sur
son ventre chaud c'est un très bon rôle
j'adore jouer des barrages malade
mentalement courriel c'est une vrai
malade mental et puis bien sûr il y a
jolly d'être 20 ans de collaboration
avec tim burton et des rôles toujours
plus surprenant du bouleversant edward
aux mains d'argent c'était en 1990 à
l'inquiétant sweeney todd leur
avant-dernier film sans oublier
l'étrange willy wonka et sa chocolaterie
dans alice johnny depp campe un
chapelier aussi fou que naïf est
touchant c'est bel et bien le vp hockey
dès que tu m'appelles je suis prêt à
faire n'importe quoi car je sais
d'avancé que l'expérience sera
particulière nous veille avec steam
c'est comme être à la maison avec alice
les fans de tim burton ne devraient pas
être déçus ils attendront ensuite sur un
nouveau challenge tout nouveau pour lui
la présidence du jury du prochain
festival de cannes